Good afternoon everyone.
It's the afternoon before replay, so I'm
glad to see so many of you still here.
Uh, today we're going to talk about how AWS
turns DDoS
into
a defensive advantage.
My name is Elena Wannick, and I lead
the shield response team.
I'm accompanied by Brian Van Hook, who is
a senior specialist essay,
and Bashar al-Rawi, who is a software
engineer with the company Figma.
Over the next hour we're going to take you behind the
scenes of AWS's DDoS
protection systems
and show you how we transform DDoS
into actual threat intelligence.
This is a 300 level course and so
there's an expectation that you have some,
uh, high level knowledge on uh
how AWS on what AWS
services do as we'll be digging
deeper into how we integrate
DDoS protection into those services.
Before we dive in, uh, let me take you
through a simple analogy
about how AWS approaches threat intelligence.
Think of the internet like uh the weather.
Most days are predictable and mild,
sunny with a chance of rain.
And when we encounter rain, simple
protection like an umbrella
will help us easily handle
it. But
Uh, Weather
has the tendency to evolve from a
drizzle to a storm,
and
just similarly, DDoS can
escalate
from simple attacks to complex
threats.
When severe weather approaches,
we take shelter,
and the same principle can apply.
To defending against major cyber threats.
Just like meteorologists use
sophisticated systems to track hurricanes,
we at AWS.
Uh Also
have evolved our defenses to
not only react to DDoS
but also adapt to emerging threats.
In today's agenda
we're going to go through
a flywheel approach
for protecting DDoS against DDoS.
Bashar is going to present
his use case on how FGM
has used that approach to help benefit
them, uh, and then we'll
end with some
best practices that you can take away
to help make your
systems more resilient.
To kick us off
Uh, we're going to dig into how DDoS
has
developed over the years.
DDoS threats can target any
type of application on the internet,
and broadly speaking, bad
actors commonly send commands to
botnets to issue large DDoS traffic.
For reflection attacks, bad actors scan the
internet for open ports like
DNS or NTP,
and then they
use those ports to
direct traffic,
uh, reflect it off of those ports, and then amplify
it either up to
100 or 1000 times the
original size in order to overwhelm
the endpoint.
For proxy-driven attacks,
threat actors
use open or private HTTPP
HTTP proxies,
and they use these to redirect
requests,
uh, to disrupt websites' availability.
Generally these attacks
hit various layers within the OSI model, and
they aim to
disrupt your
availability, overwhelm your
network capacity.
Uh, overload your connection tracking and,
uh, generally overload your
application server.
Uh
I'm gonna talk through
how the threats have evolved over the years.
So in the early to mid 2000s,
we mostly saw reflection and amplification
attacks,
and at that time we were
getting on hosts and editing IP tables
and
uh doing this per host kind of on the fly
to protect services like Cloudfront and Route
53.
This was
complicated and unsophisticated, and so we
knew we needed to evolve our approach.
Uh, in the 2010s,
attacks evolved to leverage botnets,
and
we responded to this by deploying packet
scrubbing hardware across our
network edge
in order to centralize mitigation
in 2012.
We then introduced automated mitigations
in 2013 in order to kind of help
get the humans out of the loop and, and
make it more automated.
Then in uh WAF and Shield were
released a couple of years later in order
to provide better customization
for mitigations,
uh, and then uh in
the 2020s,
we saw the rise of HTTP
driven proxy, uh, floods,
and we responded to this by launching
the shield application layer auto mitigation
in 2021.
And then just this year
we also released the
WAF anti-DDoS rule group,
and we'll dig deeper. Brian will dig deeper
into that, uh, in a little bit.
OK, so, now that we have some background
context,
uh, around,
you know, uh, DDoS over time,
let's talk about how AWS thinks about
addressing DDoS.
So we're gonna go on this journey through this flywheel
that we call the 360 degrees of DDoS,
uh, and this kind of represents how we think about.
Uh, producing threat intelligence
to protect ourselves, uh, from DDoS
attacks. So we went
through kind of a journey of
how, uh, threat actors have evolved over
time. It starts with a threat actor.
Uh, we then
dive deeply into
the telemetry that we
collect across our targeted endpoints.
And then we evolve that into, we analyze
the signal to evolve that into actionable
threat intelligence.
From there we show
how, uh,
we show how AWS threat intelligence
is built into AWS
services for improved
endpoint protection.
And then finally we wrap up with uh
we wrap up with
actual efforts to disrupt and take
down threat actors in order to
improve
resilience from DDoS across the internet.
OK. So,
let's get into the telemetry piece for
what we observe on our targeted endpoints.
ALAS's massive network
provides a real-time comprehensive view
of global internet traffic
and, and also not just global but also regional
because we're spread across
various locations.
Just to give you an idea of the scale,
on average,
we see a peak
total rate.
Of
60 terabits per 2nd,
billion packets per 2nd,
and 105 million requests per
second, this is the peak rate that we see on average
every single day.
This is an enormous amount of traffic to have
to sift through,
which
means that, uh,
we have a lot
to, to have to dig through to
get some good information out of it.
Meteorologists face a similar problem,
ah, when forecasting the weather.
If they were just looking at the temperature outside, they
wouldn't get a good understanding of what it
actually is like out there.
And so
much like
meteorologists set up weather stations to
measure things like pressure, humidity,
UV index, etc.
We need to be able to gather
data on more than just IP
address. To
do that
We've strategically integrated detection systems
across AWS
to capture different aspects of the traffic.
When DDoS traffic is destined for an
AWS endpoint, it first hits our
network layer detection systems,
and this system sees
kind of what we call top talker traffic, so the,
the peak of the peak traffic coming
through, and it's more on the
bite and packet layer,
uh, protoc uh sorry, uh, it's more on
the, the bite
and.
Uh,
common vectors that we see in
the IP and protocol layers.
Our next system
is in our edge services like AWS
Global Accelerator, Cloudfront,
uh, Elastic load balancing,
and these systems see
information more based off of,
you know, top rev requests, TCP
connections, and,
uh,
and ASN, etc.
Further in,
we also have a detection component in WAAF,
and this is,
you know, a header order also
requests,
uh, header combos as well
as request combos.
And then deeper into our,
uh, the kind of the last stop in our detection
systems, we also have a fleet of honey pots
that detect through direct threat
actor interaction.
We'll dig into this in just a few minutes.
OK, so
Across all of these detection systems
year to date, we've seen over 700,000
network layer detections and over
900,000 application layer
connection uh detections,
and this has kind of helped us funnel down
that raw telemetry that we've seen
all across our network into
kind of more
specified information on traffic anomalies.
But that being said, this is still a ton
to have to sift through.
So we need to take it one step further, which is
where threat intelligence comes in.
And for me this is kind of the fun stuff.
So doing that has a few challenges.
We collect so much data
that our detection systems, uh,
we need to be able to form it into some meaningful
way to uh
to prevent from hindering
real users.
In DDoS we regularly see threat actors
reusing IP addresses when
sourcing DDoS traffic.
This is likely because
spinning up new infrastructure is either
costly or time consuming, and so
uh it tends to be reused.
But unfortunately, it's not just
as easy as blocking any IP address
that we detect a traffic anomaly on.
Often threat actors will
use open proxies or
they will use compromised home routers
in order to
send traffic and so if we
were to just outright block those IP
addresses, we would be,
we would be impacting legitimate users.
Our second challenge comes in when we
Our detection systems are amazing,
but this also means that sometimes they
capture.
Large increases of traffic that are non-malicious,
commonly known as flash crowds, and so
these aren't actually DDoS.
And then last
Sometimes compromised
hosts will get patched.
And become good again.
To account for these challenges,
we have to get crafty with our traffic attributes.
So to create a good list, we run through a cycle
to continuously improve our list.
When we detect DDoS,
we run an analysis to understand how
effective our list is capturing the actual
DDoS traffic.
This analysis evaluates the match rate
that the DDoS traffic that our list
is having on the actual DDoS
traffic.
When our match rate is low,
we
inspect the traffic even further.
So what this means is we have to dig
into this funnel of traffic attributes
in order to better understand
how the DDoS herd of traffic is behaving
and how that differs from the legitimate traffic.
Once we understand that behavior, we tune our
algorithm to capture those attributes,
and this tuning process helps us better capture
the same herd-like behavior, so that way
we are able to mitigate
that same type of behavior when it repeats
in the future.
And then all of that leads to
successful mitigation.
But, as we all know,
threats are always evolving,
and sometimes DDoS vector, new DDoS
vectors crop up and evade our detections.
Uh, and when they evade our detections, that means
they're not properly getting integrated into
our lists.
This is where our honey pots come in, known as
mad pot. And so,
uh, Madpot is a fleet of AWS
honey pots, uh, that
run across the AWS network and
operate on EC2 instances.
Madpot pretends to be a vulnerable service
in order to get actors to interact with
it, and this provides AWS
intelligence
on
what the bad actors are actually trying to accomplish.
For botnet-driven DDoS,
Madpot captures
the
exploitation attempts. It then downloads,
automatically downloads, detonates,
and analyzes the malware
to identify key parts of the botnet
infrastructure.
This also allows Madpot to infiltrate
the botnet and see when the
command and control server is actually
issuing
DDoS commands
in order to run DDoS attacks.
These commands include
attack destinations, which gives us a positive
DDoS detection signal
uh to help us know when DDoS is evading
our detection systems.
We then run these through
our threat cycle in order to incorporate
them into our detection systems,
and then once they're incorporated into our detection
systems, we're then better able to
include all of those into
our
our known offenders lists.
OK, So we have two
major known offenders lists.
Uh, I'm going to start with the application or L7 known
offenders list,
and this was created in 2022,
uh, kind of around the time of this, you
know, increase of proxy-driven HTTP
flood,
uh, and it was really to help combat
that rise of of attack pattern.
Uh, this
is curated on bad actors sending
web-based, so HTTP or HTTPS
type traffic.
Uh, but one thing I want to know is
request level traffic does not match
one for one for
network layer packets.
So what that means is
that. You can cram
many requests into a
single network packet, and so often
threat actors will exploit this by cramming
a ton of application layer
requests into a single packet, and
so it gets a little bit challenging
when looking at the traffic because it doesn't,
it doesn't equally match to
things that would congest our network capacity.
And so
we actually have to terminate TLS
in order to better understand how many
requests are coming into the application.
We've seen great benefit using this list to mitigate
um uh as a mitigation tool
and integrated it early on into Cloudfront
and WAF,
and some exciting news is just this
year,
we also integrated it into elastic
load balancing or application uh load
balancer, so that way it has some extra
built-in DDoS resilience.
Our second list
was developed just this year, and it's the
network layer known offenders list, and
it focuses on bit and packet heavy
attacks, and this was curated
using the detection data that we have
on our
network layer detection systems.
To dig into the effectiveness of this list
and highlight how it's both helping
globally and regionally, I'm gonna go over
two case studies.
For the first case study, I want to walk through a recent
UDP vector that we've seen out in the wild.
Uh, the concept is pretty straightforward.
It's a UDP flood,
but what makes it challenging is that the
threat actors send a distributed
amount of traffic
with both the source ports
randomized and the destination
ports randomized.
So what this means is it's really challenging
to be able to pinpoint the traffic
to any one
of these attributes or any one of these
ports because they're all being randomized.
Uh, previously or earlier in the year,
we weren't actually able to detect these,
and
we were able to lean on detection
systems like Madpot and our other, uh, other
telemetry in order to help us
understand this traffic profile
and with all of that.
We were then able to feed it into our
detection systems
which then had the positive feedback
loop of getting integrated into
our network layer mitigations,
uh sorry, our network layer known offenders,
and this list is used
today mostly to protect AWS
network infrastructure.
For the second example, we'll examine a
regional case study
where DDoS vectors, uh, unlike the past
one where it was particularly UDP randomization,
the DDoS vectors were a bit more varied.
Uh, as I mentioned, this list is broadly,
uh,
protecting AWS infrastructure.
And when analyzing the effectiveness,
we discovered something interesting in one
particular region.
So when
uh we investigated, the list
was only seeing a small percentage
of
DDoS in this area.
The thing that's strange is we were
accurately detecting the floods,
but when we,
when we checked out the match rate.
Of the amount of traffic
that our known offenders list was having, it was pretty
low relative to other threats we
were seeing in other regions.
Uh, so, upon a
on
further investigation
we found that the attacking IP addresses were
uniquely regional.
These threat actors were specifically targeting
this area
rather than participating on a broader
global threat landscape.
So to improve our protection coverage,
we analyzed the traffic attributes.
Refined or inclusion criteria,
uh, and this allowed us to better capture
that threat actor and those IPs,
so when they sent traffic again,
we were able to mitigate them with our known offenders
list. All
right, now I've shown you how AWS
curates threat intelligence. I'm gonna hand it
over to Brian so he can show you how we've baked
it into our services.
Thank you. All
right, now that you've seen how we
curate and invest in all of this great threat
intelligence,
what should we do with it to protect customers?
Well, we integrate that threat intelligence
into
a number of AWS services
and
This helps those services provide mitigation
capabilities for customers
and as you'll see some of these capabilities
are built in and always on
to protect all customers
while other capabilities require
you to opt in to certain features based on
the type of workload that you have.
Now application traffic is
often based on HTTP,
so common examples there are websites
or maybe a rest API.
But there are a lot of non-HTTP
workloads out there as well.
Uh, some examples might be a back-end
gaming server that's running a
popular
massively multiplayer game,
or maybe you're operating your own DNS
resolvers.
So next we're gonna talk about some
DDoS resiliency best practices
for both of these categories of workloads,
and let's start with non-HTTP
workloads.
So here you see I have a non-HTTP workload
running in a couple of private subnets
that's done intentionally to
reduce and limit exposure to the public
internet. And we also
recommend using
a mechanism
that automatically scales your workload
to respond to an unexpected
flood that wasn't fully mitigated so that
you can absorb it and protect your business.
It's also very important
where possible to use an intelligent load
balancing service.
Here I'm using network load balancer,
and this will evenly distribute incoming
traffic across the entire
fleet. And you'll see that this is
also sitting in private subnets
again, very important to limit
your exposure to the public internet.
Now for this type of workload, we recommend using
AWS Global Accelerator.
Global Accelerator
is a networking service that
improves performance and reliability.
By routing your traffic over the
AWS global network instead of the
Internet. So with Global
Accelerator you get static IPs
that are any cast
from the AWS Edge network,
which means your client traffic is routed
to the closest Edge location
and then from there it's routed to your
VPC over the AWS global
network
and what's really great about this is that
it works even for VPC
resources that are private like our NLB
in this case.
All right, so at all of these edge locations
there are, are
many built-in DDoS mitigations,
and I'm going to cover a few here.
The first is that we rate limit
application layer and network layer known
offenders, and this is based on the threat
intelligence that Elena outlined earlier.
We don't outright block this traffic
because there are times when these known offender
lists can contain legitimate
services that customers want to use
but that have been abused recently
and might end up on this list, so we can't outright
block at all.
We also block thin floods.
So as you probably know, the sin packets the
first step in a TCP three-way handshake,
and the server responds with a syNAC
and then waits for an AC from the client.
Well, the sin flood
attempts to overwhelm the server by exhausting
the sin queue, which is going to deny
legitimate connections.
So this is mitigated at our edge
locations using something called a sin proxy.
So instead of storing that sin,
we encode the connection information
into a sequence number that's sent back to the
client. And when legitimate
clients respond to that request,
we decode the connection information
and use that to reconstruct the connection
state to complete the three-way handshake.
Next up is a what is called
a push act flood,
so this happens after the
three-way handshake is complete.
Um, clients can send
packets with a push flag set if they
want to. That's normal,
um, and this acts as a
directive for the server
to take the data out of that packet
and immediately push it up to the
application layer without buffering.
So a push back flood creates
a situation where there's a continuous
state of urgency.
Uh, and if you look at these packets
on a normal basis, they represent a
very small percentage
typically of total TCP traffic,
so we aggressively rate limit these
types,
uh, this type of traffic,
and this helps avoid a state of continuous
urgency.
The last I'll mention is that we blocked suspicious
UDP traffic.
This is based on port numbers that are
typically only relevant outside of cloud
environments.
The next piece here
is that it's important to protect your global accelerator
endpoint with AWS Shield Advance.
So with Shield Advance, it will place mitigations
using.
Thresholds that are twice as sensitive
as shield standard,
and these mitigations will stay
in place based on exponentially increasing
TTLs
to help mitigate frequently reoccurring
attacks.
Now also with Shield Advance you gain access to
the Shield Response team,
and this is a team
of DDoS response engineers
all around the world
that you can engage to get help troubleshooting
more complex issues that you
haven't been able to mitigate,
and they can help you implement
sophisticated mitigations in your environment
and we are of course fortunate to have Elena
managing that team for us at AWS.
All right, let's move on to HTTP workloads.
So this part looks similar. We have an HTTP
workload
again running in private subnets to
reduce internet exposure,
and we're using an auto scaling mechanism
to ensure you can scale out if you need to
to absorb an unmitigated flood.
We're also using
An intelligent load balance load
balancing service. In this case it's an
application load balancer because it's HTTP aware.
And this will evenly distribute traffic
across your fleet as well.
Great idea,
and you'll see that this is also in
private subnets to reduce internet exposure.
You may be wondering how are your clients going to reach
this load balancer if it's sitting in
a private subnet that's not reachable from the
internet. Well,
for all HTTP workloads exposed
to the internet, we recommend using Amazon
Cloudfront,
our managed CDN service.
A relatively new feature with Cloudfront
is called VPC Origins.
This lets you define
a VPC origin in Cloudfront
that references a resource in your
VPC that's private.
Then you can set up a cloud front distribution
using the VPC origin which
will route traffic over the Abys global
network in a way that doesn't require your
origin to be exposed to the public internet
at all.
So most of you that are using Cloudfront
might have origins that are exposed to the
internet, and I strongly encourage you
to take a look at this feature if you haven't yet.
Also at all of our cloud front edge
locations
we rate limit application layer
known offender traffic again this is based on
the threat intelligence that Elena outlined
earlier.
And at these edge locations we block
all known network layer threats.
Now with Cloudfront, we recommend
protecting your distributions with
AWS WAF.
Now ADBS WAF has been around since 2015
and it's evolved to address a wide variety
of threats,
but there are a few here that are
specific and unique to DDoS threats.
The first is a new managed rule group
this year called the Anti-DoS managed
rule Group,
and I'm going to dive deeper into this,
uh, in a bit.
Another one I have listed here is the DDoS
IP list,
and this is a managed rule with an AWBSWAF
that has a list of IPs that's very similar
to the application known offenders list
that we rate limit at these edge locations.
And as you'll see, you can use this rule to tailor
your mitigations in AWSSWAF if you
need to,
and we'll go through that as well.
Now before we get into the anti-DDOS
rule group, there are a couple
of AWS WAF features that
we'll review first.
The first is WAF rule labels.
The second one is the challenge
action. So
here's a request that might be coming into your
application where it has a URI of terraform.
And the source of this request is
Mars,
so we're getting a request from Mars just to keep things
a little interesting here.
So WAF rules, they typically inspect
one element of a request like maybe
the URI or query arguments
or the body of a request or the source
IP source geo
things of that nature
and often
that WAF rule generates a signal that
by itself is not enough to decide ultimately
what you wanna do with that request.
So
It would be nice if WAF rules could annotate
a request by adding metadata
that could then be inspected by other rules
to make a final decision on what to do with that
request based on a combination of signals,
and that is where rule labels come into
play. So when this
request comes in to your system and it's inspected
by AWS WAF.
Let's say this rule looks at the URI and
says if it's slashed terraform.
I'm just gonna count this request. I'm not going to block
it or allow it,
and when you do that, you can have this rule
attach a label to that request.
So currently terraforming a planet
is kind of expensive, so we're
just going to label this with expensive and
so now the request
inside of Adabis WAF looks like this.
It's got one label on it called expensive.
The next rule comes into play and it's looking
at the source geo,
and if that is Mars, that's currently
a hazardous location to operate, so
we're going to add another label called hazardous.
And now the request has two labels
on it
expensive and hazardous.
The third rule now comes into play and
you'll see that it's not actually looking at any
of the original fields on the HTTP
request. It's just looking at labels
and it's looking at for both of these labels
and if they both are present, it's going to
make a decision to block
this request
because maybe your business isn't quite ready yet
to perform
a project that's both this expensive and this
hazardous.
Next up is challenge action.
So when your web
application receives a flood of
traffic, you have to decide what to
do with it.
Now you could just block all of it,
but that is almost certainly going to cause
false positives because it's a mix of good
and bad traffic.
So it would be nice if there was a way for AWS
WAF to respond to traffic during
a flood
that disrupts the malicious traffic
but does not impact the experience
of a normal user,
and that is where the challenge action
comes into play.
So here we have a client, you
don't know if it's good or bad,
sending a request to your login page.
And the cookie is blank, which just means
we haven't seen this client before.
So ADFS WAF is going to look at this request
and if the URI is log in,
we're not gonna allow or block the request,
we're gonna respond with a challenge.
So what happens here is the WAF
returns some HTML content
to the client that contains an embedded
script. Now
the client needs to run this script
because what it does is it collects metadata
about the client environment and we call this
a fingerprint.
Now the script introduces
a computational cost
that's expensive for botnets at
scale to operate,
but it's not something a normal human would
notice.
And also in the context of DDoS.
Usually what's happening is the client,
the driver is just simply trying to overwhelm
you with requests and it's not even paying
attention to the response at all, let alone
take the time to run a script.
So this script
generates a fingerprint. The fingerprint is
sent back to A ofus WA where it's evaluated,
and what we're doing here is
trying to determine if we think that this is a human
or a bot, something that's not a human.
If it is a human
We generate an encrypted token
that's sent back to the client.
And then the client stores that token
in a cookie,
resends the request.
Now this rule evaluates the request again,
and if it sees that there's a valid waft token
in the cookie, it just moves on to the next
rule to complete this handshake
process. All
right, now that we've looked at WAF rule
labels and the challenge action, let's get into
this anti-DDoS rule group and see how it
works.
So you're following best practices and you've got
a cloud front distribution set up and
you're seeing traffic coming from a
wide variety of clients.
And you've also protected your cloud front distribution
with AWS WF
and you have implemented this new
anti-DDoS managed rule group.
So what happens right away is that the WAF
starts to learn
what normal traffic looks like for
your web application.
And we call this a baseline.
This baseline is established within 15
minutes.
It's a rolling baseline
that's updated every 5 seconds.
Now one of the great things about this baseline
is that
we can detect anomalies in traffic
that are unique to your workload.
And not all anomalies
necessarily though are bad.
You might have a flash flood of traffic that's
a spike in traffic from legitimate
users and you don't want to block that.
And you need a way to differentiate the good
from a bad spike.
And we use the threat intelligence
that Elena outlined earlier to help make
that differentiation.
Now when there's a malicious spike in traffic,
we call this a DDoS event,
and every request that arrives
during a DDoS event is labeled
with event detected by these rules,
and you'll see how that can come into play later
if you want to tailor
the behavior here.
Now during a DDoS event, not every
request that comes in is malicious.
There's going to be good traffic in the mix as
well. And so what
this rule group does is it assigns a suspicion
score,
and there's
3 levels here low, medium, and high,
and you can see the corresponding labels that
are added to suspicion, uh,
to requests based on the level of suspicion that's
there. And this is
great because if you need to, you can fine
tune the sensitivity of this rule group
based on these suspicion levels if you need
to, so you'll see how that works in a bit.
The last piece here is that in this rule
group you can define
a regular expression
that essentially determines which
URI's in your
application support the challenge action
so that helps you narrow down
the scope for which these rule
groups will respond with a challenge or not.
Now for most customers,
You really don't need to understand any more than what
I've already covered.
Uh, this rule group works great for most customers
using the defaults, but since this is a 300
level talk, we're going to go a little bit deeper.
Alright, so what are the rules in this rule group?
Well, there's 3 of them.
The first one is called Challenge all during
event.
So this rule will respond
to with a challenge for every single
request that comes in during a DDoS event
that's been detected.
And it but it only does this for requests
that are challengeable based on that regular expression
you've defined earlier
so it doesn't look at the suspicion score at
all.
So you can think of this rule as having
the maximum sensitivity
because it challenges everything.
Now, if you want to tailor the sensitivity
of this behavior,
you can put this rule in count mode,
which brings the next rule into play.
And this is called Challenge
DDoS requests.
So with this rule it's doing something very similar
only during a DDoS event
it's going to challenge requests, but
only if they are
suspicious.
And by default the sensitivity for this
rule is high and this is where
you define the sensitivity of that rule
and what this really means is that.
It's highly sensitive, which means it's
going to challenge any request that
has
some level of suspicion,
really any level of suspicion.
Now let's say
it's being a little too aggressive and you
don't want it to challenge
requests that have low suspicion,
you can set this from high to medium to make it
less sensitive,
uh, and so on.
The third rule is called DDoS requests.
And this will actually block
requests that are suspicious during a DDoS
event and by default the sensitivity
to this rule is low
to avoid false positives, so it's only
going to block
requests that have the highest suspicion level
during a DDoS event.
Alright, so let's talk about how you might wanna
tailor the behavior of AWS WAF
going beyond
the capability you get out of the
anti-DDoS managed rule group.
So here we have edge locations off on the right
and you've got Cloudfront set up with a distribution
that's protected by AWS WAF
and you've already got the anti-DDoS rule group in
play. Let's walk
through 4 different types of traffic
that you might want to consider when tailoring
the behavior here.
The first is that
You might have normal users that are sending
around 50 requests per minute.
And you'll see here that some of these users might
be using an open proxy, which is
perfectly normal.
Unfortunately some of these users
are using an open proxy that's red here
indicating that it has been recently abused
and is actually on our
known offenders list,
so it's a bit of a tricky scenario that we have to deal
with. The
next use case is
a threat actor that's using an IP address
that has bad
DDoS reputation, and they're sending 4
times more traffic than you would expect.
And then here's another user that's sending
20 times more traffic than you would expect
again using an IP that has a bad reputation.
And then our fourth scenario here
is a thread actor that's using an IP address
that doesn't have a bad reputation. It's
actually good as far as we can tell.
And
they're sending over 100 times more traffic
than you would expect.
So what are we going to do with these situations?
Well, on the lower right corner.
Let's say that you implement this DDoS
IP list rule that I mentioned earlier,
so this is a list of IPs
that has our known offenders based on our
threat intelligence, and you could just put this in
block mode,
for example, to start off.
Well, what's going to happen here?
Is that this top threat actor,
well, all their traffic will be allowed
because they're using an IP that doesn't have
a bad reputation, so it won't be
blocked by the DDoS IP list, and
we call this a false negative.
This is not the outcome you want.
The next two
will be blocked because they're using IPs that
are known offenders. That's all good.
But here
we're blocking normal users because they're
using an open proxy that's been abused
recently and we call this a false positive.
And it's also a scenario that
uh this is not the right outcome in this case.
So what can we do to avoid false positives
and false negatives here?
Well, let's back up a little bit.
And try something else.
So here
we still have the anti-DDoS rule group in play,
but. Remember
it is labeling traffic during a DDoS
event with this event detective label, so let's
see if we could take advantage of that
and I'm using numbers here because the ordering is
actually important on what we're walking through next.
So let's put the DDoS IP list back into
play, but instead of putting it in block
mode, we'll just put it in count mode.
And the value here is that it will label
requests during a during a DDoS
event
with the DDoS list label.
And what this means is that it gives you
some metadata to tell if a request is coming
from an IP
that is a known offender.
Now this DDoS list label is not
the actual label for this rule. I've abbreviated
it so it fits on the slide.
So the 3rd rule we're going to add to this web ACL
is a rate-based rule.
So rate-based rules are great.
What they do is they count the number of requests
coming in
by aggregating on some
sort of key.
And the key I'm using here is a source IP
so it's gonna count every request by source
IP.
And it does this counting over a rolling time
window,
and I'm using a one minute window here.
And you set a limit, and the limit I'm using
here is 2000.
So what this rule does is it's going
to block traffic
from any source IP that
has sent more than 2000 requests during the
past 1 minute.
Which is great.
So this is going to handle the, the
top situation here.
Now you might be tempted to just set this
limit of 2000 to something much lower
to address the other
use cases here,
um,
but you want to be careful with that because you might have
normal users, for example,
that are behind a corporate proxy
or a net gateway of some kind
and you have a big
collection of users that essentially
all look like they're coming from the same public IP
address.
And that'll all get aggregated together and it
could easily reach
higher, much higher limits here. So
with rate-based rules,
the rule of thumb here is to err on the
side of using limits that are higher than you might
think to avoid false positives
because they're still very effective at
handling very large floods.
The 4th rule is another rate-based rule.
Here we have the limit much lower. It's down to 500
per minute.
But the scope here says DDoS list,
so what this means is it's only going to count
requests coming from source IPs
that are on that list.
So there's some level of risk here
with that traffic, so it's safer to use a lower
limit should not affect normal users.
The last rule we're going to add is yet
another rate-based rule.
So this one is also counting by source
IP,
but the scope here is using DDoS list
label plus a particular
URI.
So you might pick a URI that is
especially sensitive to DDoS threats
within your application.
So it's only going to count requests for that
URI and only if they're coming from a
source that is suspicious.
So you can use a much lower limit here
and sort of layer these rate-based rules
in a way.
Now just in case normal users
kind of wander into this territory of sending
100 requests per minute for a particular URI,
you don't want to impact those users,
so we're using a challenge action here to
avoid false positives.
Now the anti-DDOS rule group
adds this label of event detected.
You could put that label
in the scope of all these rate-based rules
if you want to further narrow them down
so they only come into play during an actual
DDoS event,
which would further reduce the risk of false positives.
Alright, with that, let's hear from Bashar
on how Figma
has used these capabilities earlier this year
to mitigate real world DDoS threats.
All right, thank you, Brian.
Hi, my name is Bashar, and I'm super excited to be
talking about's journey with DDoS
attacks over the last couple of years.
So what is Figma?
Figma is the platform that designers,
product managers, and software engineers
use to turn their ideas
into shipped products.
We have almost over 13
million users who use Figma products
every month,
and over 95% of the Fortune
500 companies use Figma
products today.
Almost every product that you use
has been designed in
in the browser.
Our customers connect to our
services using their web browser,
mobile or desktop apps,
and we funnel all that traffic
through a cloud front to terminate their SSL
connection closer to their location.
And then we funnel that traffic eventually
into our proxy for logging and observability,
and finally
that traffic hits our back end services
that power figmas user experiences
and collaborative features via either
our real-time
services or our application servers.
Let's take a look at some of the attack patterns that
we've seen over the last 2 years.
This graph shows about a recent
2 month period,
um, and it shows like how many requests
have hit our platform distribution
per minute.
And as you can see,
These attacks happen almost on a
weekly basis and sometimes multiple
times in a day.
They are very brief. They only last a few
minutes, and they are many orders of
magnitude more than our steady
state traffic.
There is no way
we can,
we can handle this much traffic. It's
just like not economically possible to
be provisioned for that much traffic in a steady state,
nor can we scale up quickly
enough to absorb that traffic.
And when these attacks
used to take down,
our customers could not iterate on their
designs, prototypes,
and ideas, and they literally wouldn't be
able to do their job.
So how did we approach this?
So first we try to analyze
these requests to understand
and find any signatures that we can use
in order to
step up our defenses.
So we adopted a defense in depth strategy
by trying to leverage both,
as Brian mentioned, and also
adding some protections in our proxy layer
to protect against these types of attacks.
And finally,
As these attacks have evolved,
we continue to iterate on
our monitoring, observability,
and fine tuning our protections over
time. So
how do we analyze these requests?
So we relied heavily on
WAF logging in order to
try to capture
all the raw requests that come in
and then use the cloud Watch logs insights
to analyze these requests.
to identify
any suspicious patterns such
as
trying to identify the top talker IP
addresses, or any suspicious headers
that might come in that we can use in our
rules for protections to block
these types of attacks.
Um, and so we
added some basic rules and we
also started in count mode because we didn't
want to potentially affect user traffic.
And
we try to target just like the
top toker IP addresses, GA 3s,
and any suspicious headers we've seen such as
unexpected user agents and so on.
And then we also added some rate limiting rules
on top of this
to make sure we have multiple layers of protections.
So we try to target different keys and
time windows and thresholds in order
to provide multiple layers of
protections.
So we try to rate limit the traffic per user
and by targeting the cookie header,
for example, to provide very
specific rate limit rules.
And we also added some endpoint protections
and such
such that some endpoints were more expensive than
others, and so we added some tighter limits there.
And finally we had some catch all rate
limit rules such as limiting the amount
of traffic that we get per IP address.
We had to be very careful with how many
with these thresholds because we didn't
want to block
potentially good traffic coming from corporate
IP addresses, proxies, and
open proxies as Brian mentioned.
And then eventually we ended up adopting
challenges which are really amazing
because they let you provide tighter
limits because even if there were some
false positives, the good traffic is
supposed to go through because it's supposed to be solved
by the browser,
whereas the bad traffic
will be blocked automatically.
Now these were
we added all of these rules and they were amazing,
but we were also worried that some of this traffic
might slip into our back end services
either because our rules were not
attuned perfectly or our
attackers
would evolve their attacks over time.
So what we also tried to do was
to make sure we isolate traffic
in our back end infrastructure.
And what we noticed was a lot of these
attacks came from unauthenticated
requests, for example,
and so we ended up trying to bring up replicas
of some of our backend services
and change our routing such that we would
send unauthenticated requests to like
authenticated application servers
and
authenticated requests to different
application servers that would handle authenticated
traffic
and that way.
If we get a spike, let's say for unauthenticated
traffic,
it may take down
those like those API servers that handle unauthenticated
requests, but the authenticated requests would not
be affected.
And similarly,
we try to move also some of our
application logic
to the front end and to try to actually
serve that traffic by S3, which
is a globally scalable service and such
that this traffic won't actually
eventually take down our back end services.
This was great and everything, but unfortunately
it was just like not super maintainable. Just imagine
every back end service that
you add, then you have to think about, oh, I need to
bring a different replica and I have to
for unauthenticated traffic and change all
of these routing rules.
So what we ended up doing was to try
to centralize all that intelligence
in our proxy layer.
And this is also important because
some of these rate limit rules in WA
don't kick in immediately and take about 30
seconds, and any spike in traffic
during this 32nd period
will actually take down our
back end services if we were not able to
block them immediately.
And so what did we do?
So we built a custom
go filter
and added it to our envoy proxy
that would actually provide fair sharing
between any endpoint,
priority level,
or authentication type
such that there is no,
there is no bucket here that would
take more than its fair
share of capacity as
it would do in steady state traffic.
And we also added
signing to our cookies, and we
would check for signatures here because as I
mentioned, we added rate limit rules
targeting the cookie header, but attackers
can easily just forge these cookies, so
we made sure that we can actually check
for these cookies to make sure they are signed by
FIMA, and we would reject traffic immediately.
And it's amazing to use signatures here because you don't need
to talk to any back end service, so you can do
it extremely cheaply.
Now our attackers have evolved over
time and what we noticed was these
attackers started rotating their IP addresses,
JA 3s, and so on, even
within a single attack and targeting more
critical endpoints. So we had to
continue to automate our analysis and try
to do it in semi-real time, identifying the
top tokers
and then adding them to our blocking rules
and tuning over our rate limit
rules over time.
And finally
we try to
adopt all the amazing threat intelligence
that Elena just talked about.
You know, is just like one customer, but AWS
has millions of customers. They have way more
sophisticated threat intelligence than we can possibly
do. And so we adopted
the anti-Dos rule group that Brian
just talked about and the IP reputation list
to try to identify all these spikes
and the IP
list's reputations automatically
without us trying to actually trying to
do this ourselves.
And so
this has been a really exciting journey over the last
couple of years partnering with AWS. We were
one of the early adopters for the anti-didustrial
group that we just talked about
and integrating the WAF and iOS SDK
rules in order to provide challenge support
seamlessly within our product and finally
providing a lot of product feedback
such as adding configurable time windows for
rate limit-based rules that we needed in order
to have multiple
rules targeting.
Specificities
and finally, let's just take a look at a couple of real world
examples
that just show the magnitude of these
DDoS attacks as well and how our protections
were able to protect us against these attacks.
The first example is just like a very
common example just targeting our main web
application which used to provide both an authenticated
and unauthenticated experience. And as
you can see here,
there were like 10s of millions of requests per
second. And because we had multiple
rules that we're actually working
all together in order to protect
against these attacks,
challenging this number of requests
per minute,
and for the rest of the traffic, as I mentioned, we
try to actually funnel it through S3,
which is like a globally scalable
service.
The final example here is
a more sophisticated attack that targeted one of
our API endpoints, and this
also shows how
this defense in depth strategy works
together in order to protect.
So you can see here in the second
graph,
the 1st 30 seconds, so before
kicked in,
we had our intelligent proxy.
Just react automatically and very quickly
to protect 70,000 requests
per second. If these requests came into our
back ends,
they would actually
cause some downtime.
And for the remaining period when all the
WAF rules kicked in,
we were able to rely on WAF to actually
protect for the
rest of the attack.
And with that, I'll hand it over to Elena
for some final thoughts.
All right, so we're gonna come back
to our threat intelligence cycle,
uh, on our last stop of disrupting and
taking down threat actors.
Uh, I'm gonna do this quick and then Brian's
gonna wrap us up with some best practices,
uh, but I wanted to call out
some of the cool things that AWS
has been a part of over the last year.
We worked with law enforcement in
order to.
I give them information
to help successful takedown of actual
botnet infrastructures
and.
This top one here is one that
I
would want to talk a little bit deeper into
where we were seeing
this wrapper bot issuing DDoS
that was
multi-terabit,
you know, multi-billion
packet per second floods on
a regular basis, not just towards
AWS but broadly
towards various locations on the
Internet, uh,
and.
I,
I think that it, it, I don't know if all of you
are familiar, but AWS has a set of
what we call leadership principles.
Those are kind of like guiding tenants in order
to, uh, help us ensure
that we're producing good things, and some of them are like
customer, uh, customer obsession
or earns trust.
One of my personal favorites is
success and scale bring broad responsibility.
And I really feel like this embodies
this from the perspective of
uh AWS is actively working
to dismantle and take down these threat actors
and trying to leave the Internet a
better place kind of for everybody
uh so I'm gonna do
last handover to Brian
so he can talk about some best practices.
All right, so a quick recap of
some best practices here.
So first is to auto
scale out
so that you can absorb unexpected traffic
spikes.
The next is to make sure you're load balancing across
your entire fleet
and then leverage the built-in
DDOS mitigations
that are available at AWS edge
locations.
And then do everything that you can
to minimize internet exposure.
And then protect your resources with
AWS Shield Advance and use
the new WAF anti-DDOS managed
rule group.
And then if you need
to customize that behavior, use WAF
rate-based rules
and the DDoS IP reputation
list. So
At AWS we operate
the largest public network of
any cloud provider.
And this gives us a unique view
into the DDoS challenges that our
customers face every day.
And we work relentlessly
to improve our threat intelligence so that
we can help mitigate that risk.
Now the result is a level of DDoS resiliency
that's very difficult for most
organizations to achieve on their own.
So if you're headed outside into challenging
weather, Make sure to put
AWS to work for you.
So with that, I wanna thank you for being here and
we hope to work with you in the future.
Thanks.